what is going on everybody welcome to
another
youtube video in this video what we're
gonna be talking about is the brand new
jets integra k1 dev kit
on board is the tiger k1 system on a
chip that is new from nvidia
now i have a special treat for you guys
today i actually
have one i got it in the mail and i have
not even opened it yet still got the
seal on it and everything i thought we
could open it together
so what is this chip um or actually the
entire board what do we do with it
and just you know some information on it
brand new chip
from nvidia and the main focus on this
chip so far has been mobile
so the idea is that you can put one of
these into a cell phone tablet or
whatever
and you can get xbox 360 ps3 type
graphics so for gaming on phones and all
of that
huge increase now one thing to keep in
mind is that
when gaming increases go up for
performance so does everything else on
your phone
so the performance of your phone should
become just
drastically better we're talking about
the stats that this thing has
is really the stats of your average
computer
maybe not necessarily today certainly in
storage not today but as far as
performance is concerned
maybe the average computer of two years
ago or
or so so probably whatever computer your
family is running today
this is just as powerful and so that's
actually really impressive
but these are just of course the claims
of nvidia i have not really tested it
and really the only tests that i've seen
so far have been put out from nvidia
one thing to just note is there's two
there's a difference here right there's
the
jetson tagger k1 dev kit which is a
development kit
uh focused around the tiger k1 chip
okay and so the dev kit is a little
bigger i haven't actually seen it but
according to the measurements it should
be about twice the size of your
your typical raspberry pi okay and
the next question would be how how
powerful is it you know let's say
uh in terms of the raspberry pi instead
of ps3 or xbox 360.
the raspberry pi pulls about 24
g flops whereas the tiger k1 again
the claimed number is
326 g flops so significantly more now
how about the price well the raspberry
pi
is about forty dollars people like to
quote this like twenty to thirty dollar
range for raspberry pi
let me know if you see a raspberry pi on
sale a new one for twenty to
thirty dollars i would like to buy them
uh
so anyway the raspberry pi more often
than not
is more like thirty dollars unless you
buy in bulk or i mean forty dollars
unless you buy in bulk
or you get it with you know something
together like i just found like a
raspberry pi in the camera module i
think for fifty dollars
so that was actually a really good deal
but anyway
that aside so about 40 dollars i would
say for uh your typical
raspberry pi the tiger k1 dev kit 192
99 i believe let me look on uh
new egg real quick yeah 192.99
as a sort of salute to the amount of
cores
it's got a kepler gpu with 192 cuda
enabled cores
so what does this mean well um
basically the if you look at like the
raspberry pi
uh especially when you consider
something like python or something like
that where
when python doesn't really utilize your
entire gpu because
it's python by its nature is a single
threaded
application and so what you have to do
if you want to get
the full processing power out of your
cpu with python
is you have to either do threading in a
somewhat um pseudo way
or you can do something like pai cuda or
use like anaconda
something like that that uses a cuda
enabled gpu to do gpu processing
now that's what makes this so special is
because
obviously we have no problem uh maxing
out our
uh raspberry pi uh really one python
script
to get that thing cooking
but with this one python script probably
would not
max out this gpu and so you would start
having to
thread or run multiple scripts to get
that processing up
whereas here we can actually use cuda
and if you do it right you
actually make a much more efficient
program and all that so
this can get very powerful very fast
at least according to specifications i
like to test them
so also if you caught up with my last
video
my intentions with this are a little bit
different than you know gaming
or mobile gaming or mobile anything um
i guess mobile actually is a pretty good
word but not in the sense of cell phones
and stuff
um i'd like to put this on a quadcopter
and i do actually have my quadcopter
i built this uh just a few days ago
and i finished it yesterday one of the
pieces was bad so i had to buy another
one
so anyway i will probably be putting
this dev kit right on top here
replace this uh kk board with that
and i'd like to make this an autonomous
quadcopter that was my promise to nvidia
anyway so
um i have to at least try that and
that's really what i have more interest
in i have a computer already
now i am kind of curious the raspberry
pi is a full computer
i'm curious to find out if this jets
integr k1 can actually be a full
uh usable computer because the raspberry
pi is totally usable
but it takes like three seconds to open
up an internet browser
and then actually browse the internet it
it's just very slow it's very tedious
now for you know forty dollars that's
still
very good um so i'm curious about the
jetson
tiger k1 a couple of things it's got two
gigs of ram
16 gigs of storage but there's sata and
sd so you can plug more stuff in there
if you didn't want to have a hard drive
you could use an sd card not recommended
at least from what i found with the
raspberry pi
the sd card is not a good storage system
even though it works great for you know
taking pictures or whatever
and it seems to work okay on my cell
phone
if you're doing something with a lot of
input and output you're highly likely to
burn that sd card
now i want to say there is a type of sd
card that does it better but
the name evades me so anyway uh without
further ado let's go ahead and open up
this box see what we got because i have
not opened it and i really want to open
it so
let me make some space here and we'll
aim this down now
mmm coffee okay so
uh let us break this
seal i should keep it boxed up and sell
it in a few years
anyway
if anyone is curious you can get them
apparently of course when i looked at it
on newegg it says not available i'm not
really sure who else sells this right
now
i don't have you can just search it on
nvidia i'm not an affiliate or anything
like that i don't pay me to say this
i think you can actually i don't know if
you can buy it on nvidia's website or
not
but anyway to the chip uh so here's the
board i don't know how well you guys can
see it
um it's basically taking up this entire
box
and too bad we can't really see the chip
you can look up pictures of it online to
get pictures of the chip but
over the chip is a a fan to cool it and
so
that makes a lot of sense because i bet
this chip gets pretty warmish
especially if you're using all 192
cores now the next thing let's see what
else we got in here so here's the chip
now we have a what looks to be recycled
materials
um introduction basically to the board
no problem no problem
it's like power possibly this is a
serious power my goodness
yeah this is your power uh
no more mini usb apparently
uh i want to say you could power this by
many usps where i read that but
we'll look at it in a minute and then we
got what looks to be our usb
used with something looks like a
controller i don't really know for sure
it's a mini usb well yeah it's mini usb
plug it looks like you're supposed to
use it with a controller but
i don't really i can't tell very much
this is a lego piece what looks to be a
lego piece
and then uh the plug for our power
and that would be everything so
literally the only instructions that
come with this are here
now i have kind of read up online there
is a ton of information
on nvidia's website about the tiger k1
setting it up they have a bunch of
software there for you
um so easy enough
close all this
and so i'm not really sure if this is
probably
has no use it's probably just a little
gift
to people or something i have no idea it
honestly looks like lego
someone correct me is this buttons maybe
no
i'm very curious it looks like a little
lego piece uh
anyway enough of that um then we have
this
usb cord that i'm not really sure what
its purpose is it's very specific and
what it's supposed to be used with
it looks like a controller to me but uh
it's a usb to mini usb so
whatever you wanted to use that for i'm
pretty sure
and that right there and here we have
our massive uh power
supply box here that's huge it's bigger
than like my laptops
okay anyway so there's that
and finally the uh the entire dev kit
itself
now let's see
yeah for here um before you start
playing with this you wouldn't want to
make sure you ground yourself you know
touch something metal i'm not sure if
this is plastic or metal but
you'd want to touch something metal make
sure you don't have a charge because you
could
uh ruin the entire kit but anyway
i have static down here in texas now
slowly careful easy
and here we have our tegra k1
dev kit so here we got
uh some power some io vga
audio ethernet usb i'm pretty sure that
blue stands for 3.0
dc power looks like right here
interesting interesting hdmi
zeta
honestly not even sure what j a e i'm
not really sure what this plug is here
so
let me know have to look at a picture
and figure out what that is
anyway so yeah cool so this is all of
our stuff here uh we've got a whole
bunch of
things to play with for sure
definitely going to be a lot of fun so
anyway uh
that is your tiger k1 dev kit quite the
size
at first i thought it was two right
about the size of two raspberry pi's
but this is really the size of probably
one two
three raspberry pies if we were being
honest
so quite a bit larger and i'm curious
how well it will fit on my quadcopter
it actually looks like it should fit but
let me
oh i don't knock over my coffee
so yeah it'll fit um not really sure how
well you guys can see that
but uh it'll fit just barely it's like
the perfect size
uh just trying my best not to bang
something
anyway you have to take my word for it
it fits
so that's cool the other thing i was
going to do if that didn't fit was just
stack
raspberry pi's on there because one
raspberry pi just won't cut it
but if we uh did some
um just networking between the pods they
could all work together so
that was the backup but this will fit
it's a good thing i was
starting to worry if i needed it i
didn't realize that quad was going to be
that big i don't read specifications
usually
so i was more interested in the price of
that quad
than anything else and uh so anyway
we're lucky i
didn't get any smaller quad i would have
had to buy another one so anyways
um so that's it with the tiger k1 i'm
gonna play with it a little bit i have
never played with it so i can't really
do too much else with it until i
uh set this up there's a whole bunch
like i said documents online about
what you you need to do to get this
thing running they have a you know linux
that you can install here i'm very
curious to put a game on it and see how
well it plays i'll plug it into one of
these monitors
um probably show you guys how that how
that works anyway i wouldn't mind
testing that stuff
but then after that my biggest interest
is in the input output
and um and then cuda right so
the idea of cuda is really nice because
the board comes from nvidia
so this means we can do use all of the
development
up to this point and all of the um
you know support for cuda programming up
to this point because this is a
cuda enabled gpu so that's very exciting
so even if you didn't have a tiger k1
you could probably follow along with
some of the videos
just based on programming with a cuda
enabled gpu
that said i do actually have two cuda
enabled gpus in my main computer as well
so i could have done those anyway but um
it'll be fun to play with this little
board so that's it if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below one last look at the tiger k1
dev kit i'm having such a hard time
there we go
um so that's it excited to play with the
board
um hopefully you guys enjoyed questions
and comments below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time